Ohne Witz, ich denk heut
bestimmt schon zum 10.Mal:
Ich könnt ja was essen,
was könnt ich denn essen?
Dann fällt's mir wieder ein.
Da merkt man erst mal,
wie oft man am Tag an Essen denkt.
*Titelmusik*
Fasten, tage- oder wochenlang
nichts oder sehr wenig essen,
gibt es als Brauch
in allen Weltreligionen.
Tiere machen es schließlich auch,
gezwungenermaßen.
Ein Königspinguin kann 5 Monate
ohne Nahrung auskommen,
lebt dann
nur von seinen Fettpolstern
und verliert einfach mal
die Hälfte seines Körpergewichts.
Da können wir Menschen nur staunen.
Dabei ist ständiges Futtern
auch nicht gerade das,
was unser Körper braucht.
Frühstück, Mittag, Abendessen:
Letztendlich essen wir immer,
wenn wir nicht gerade schlafen.
Ich hab so Hunger!
Dabei könnten wir 30 Tage lang oder
länger ohne feste Nahrung überleben.
Gesund ist sporadisches Fasten auch.
Da sind sich
sämtliche Experten einig.
Die Insulinempfindlichkeit steigt,
das beugt Diabetes Typ 2 vor.
Entzündungsreaktionen werden
verringert.
Und das Verdauungssystem kann sich
mal ein bisschen erholen.
Das sind nur einige
von vielen Vorteilen.
Dies ist der erste Zucker, den ich
zu mir nehme seit...
36 Stunden.
Aber für den Kopf?
Ihr kennt es doch sicherlich auch,
dass ihr euch vor Hunger
auf nichts mehr konzentrieren könnt.
Macht dann längeres Fasten
nicht einfach nur dumm?
Hmm...
Kuchen! *Signal ertönt*
Kurzfristig schon, aber langfristig
leiden die kognitiven Fähigkeiten
unter einem erhöhten
Blutzuckerspiegel.
Ein dauerhaft
erhöhter Blutzuckerspiegel
führte bei Studien-Teilnehmern
zu schlechteren Ergebnissen
bei Gedächtnistest.
Außerdem kann man in Fasten-Kliniken
Folgendes beobachten:
Nach etwa 3 sehr harten Tagen
steigt die Stimmung der Faster
plötzlich wieder.
Vielleicht, weil sie inzwischen
völlig von Sinnen sind?
Naja, so ähnlich.
Man muss das so sehen:
Bei unseren Vorfahren
kam das ja durchaus mal vor,
dass man 3 Tage lang
nichts zu essen bekam.
Das ist für den Körper
erst mal ziemlich ermüdend.
Ich saß die letzte Stunde einfach
nur auf nem Stuhl im Wohnzimmer
und fand das
unglaublich anstrengend.
Wenn man sich dann
in seine Höhle schlafenlegt,
kann es sein,
dass man nie wieder aufwacht.
Ich befürchte, ich muss einen
kleinen Powernap halten.
Um genau das zu verhindern,
löst unser Gehirn
Gefühle der Euphorie aus,
damit wir uns aufrappeln
und nach Nahrung suchen.
Durchs Essen nehmen wir u.a.
die Aminosäure Tryptophan auf.
Dies ist eine Vorstufe
des Glückshormons Serotonin.
Wenn wir nichts zu essen bekommen,
verfallen wir deswegen zuerst
in eine Art kleine Depression.
Es ist 2:30 Uhr und
ich kann an nichts anderes ess...
Ich wollte grad wirklich sagen:
Ich kann an nichts anderes essen.
Bei längerem Fasten
wird dieser Mangel ausgeglichen,
indem weniger von dem Glückshormon
Serotonin entfernt wird,
und so die Konzentration
wieder steigt.
Es ist fast halb 12 Uhr abends,
ich fühle mich ziemlich
fit, super wach.
Unser Körper hat also
eine Antidepressivum-Funktion,
die durchs Fasten
in Gang gebracht wird.
Doch bevor ihr euch jetzt
euphorisch ins Fasten stützt,
informiert euch
bitte bei eurem Arzt,
in welchem Ausmaß
das für euch gesund ist.
Bedenkt außerdem,
dass die meisten Menschen, zu Recht,
nicht in ihrem
stressigen Arbeitsalltag fasten,
sondern sich zu einem Fastenurlaub
in eine entsprechende Klinik
o.Ä. begeben.
Dann gibt es noch
sogenanntes Intervall-Fasten,
was ggf. etwas
alltagstauglicher ist.
Also informiert euch
und verwechselt Fasten nicht
mit einer sinnvoll Diät
für schnellen Gewichtsverlust.
Schneller und nachhaltiger
Gewichtsverlust
schließen sich
sowieso kategorisch aus.
Und Fasten
ist auch keine Kompensation für eine
ungesunde Ernährung.
Schönschlau!
Untertitel:
ARD Text im Auftrag von Funk (2017)
Ihr habt gerade schon
so ein paar Ausschnitte gesehen:
Ich habe ein kleines
Selbstexperiment gemacht,
um zu testen, ob die Fasten-Euphorie
nach 3 Tagen auch bei mir eintritt.
Das gibt es hier bzw.
ab Sonntag dann auf diesem Kanal.
Was ist mit euch:
Habt ihr schon mal gefastet
und was waren
eure Erfahrungen damit?
Schreibt's in die Kommentare!
Wir sehen uns nächsten Donnerstag,
bis dahin: Bleibt sicher!